[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
dure semaine pour les champions
autoproclamés de l'écologie jeudi la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
condamne la france ont lentement pour
avoir dépassé ces limites de dioxyde de
carbone de manière systématique et
répétée
après dix années de procédure le même
jour votre ministère publié un rapport
accablant publions les mauvais résultats
de la france en matière d'émissions de
co2 de dégradation de la biodiversité ou
de la qualité deux eaux souterraines ses
faiblesses chroniques en matière
environnementale sont à rapprocher de
l'échec violent de votre politique
fiscale privilégions une écologie
punitive ayant mis le pays en très
grande tension l'an passé à la suite
d'une hausse brutale non concertée et
confiscatoires de la taxe carbone dans
le contexte de changement climatique
actuel et sur la base de ces mauvais
résultats et alors comme un peu plus de
deux ans
trois ministres déjà été en charge de
l'écologie allez vous mener une
politique distributive ou bien mettre
vos pas dans ceux de messieurs hulot et
de rugy merci
[Applaudissements]